President Lincoln also said at that time:
'America is the last best hope on earth.'
Would he repeat that now?
And would you repeat it?
Lincoln spoke of the United States as the
last best hope on earth because the United States
was the last and only and first successful
democratic republic in the world.
Europe, in his time, in Lincoln's time, was
a continent in which democratic revolutions
had been suppressed.
After the spring time of nations in the revolutions
of 1848 the United States stood alone.
Then the Civil War presented a great task
and if the United States were to succeed,
it would be the last best hope as the example
of liberalism to the rest of the world.
It was not an accident that it was the gift
of the French people to the United States,
the Statue of Liberty, that now stands in the
New York harbour.
It is a statue that was given to represent
the victory in the Civil War.
That statue holds the Declaration of Independence
in one arm, which proclaims that all men are
created equal.
At its feet are the broken chains of slavery.
Also significantly and symbolically, the Statue
of Liberty does not face towards
the United States but towards Europe.
Even in the 19th century.
And now the United States also radiates out
to the rest of the world.
The most important thing about being the last
best hope is to be an example.
And that means that the United States must
reform its own democracy, and that this is
an internal process.
And if it is to be the last best hope it requires
ourselves to create the American example.